is that a hand grenade or an easter egg
and halo the answer is both halo is
bringing the video game series to life
and weighs large and small and paramount
plus and only real fans will recognize
the series as deeper references these
are the easter eggs you missed in halo
episode 1.
halo starts out on the planet madrigal
one of humanity's outer colonies and a
major center for the rebellion against
the unsc in the opening scenes of the
show madrigal is shown to be relatively
barren save for occasional mining
colonies this peaceful facade is
shattered by a surprise attack by the
covenant who kill all but one inhabitant
to the settlement they target the saint
healy warriors more commonly known as
the elites and games are in turn
dispatched by the unsc spartan squad
silver team led by the master chief the
spartans
may not ring any bells for newcomers to
the halo franchise or even for those who
play the games but the planet does play
a significant role in the spin-off
novels particularly joseph staton's halo
contact harvest and tobias buckles halo
the cold protocol in the original canon
madrigal is one of the first planets to
be glassed by the covenant a genocidal
act of orbital attack that eliminates
all life on a world and renders it
essentially uninhabitable the show's
version of magical is a bit different as
it remains unglassed well into
humanity's war with the covenant however
with the heavy narrative focus still
being placed on the planet its original
fate may eventually catch up with it on
paramount plus as well
[Music]
the first episode of halo kicks into
high gear almost immediately with a
fierce battle between silver team and
the covenant sang healey elites it's a
great way to show off the kind of action
fans can expect from the series early on
and it also features a number of
specific references to the halo video
games several of those easter eggs come
in the form of the covenant's weapons
and sci-fi gear much of which will be
instantly recognizable for longtime fans
while the design of the saint healy
armor is a bit different in the show one
of very few design divergences their
weapons and shields are spot on right
down to the little details anyone who's
played the halo games on the higher
difficulties of heroic or legendary will
empathize with the magical militia's
inability to penetrate the elite shields
defenses that are heavily resistant to
bullets but more susceptible to plasma
weapons the new series does a great job
of keeping these qualities of the
shields consistent another great touch
in the magical fights is the plasma
pistol a classic covenant weapon from
the games when one of the silver team
spartans fires a charged shot from the
plasma pistol and an enemy saint healy a
vent on top of the gun pops open to vent
the excess heat just as it does in the
games
additionally the magical fight features
incredibly faithful recreations of the
energy sword in the elites active
camouflage
if you thought the halo show would break
the trend of awkward first person
sequences and video game adaptations
you'd be wrong the first episode barely
gets 10 minutes deep before the camera
jumps inside master chief's helmet to
show a heads up display or hud that's
very reminiscent to the video games
right down to a radar in the bottom
left-hand corner targeting recticles and
a readout of his currently equipped
weapon and available ammunition it's a
bit silly but that doesn't stop the show
from using the hud view repeatedly
through the magical battle although the
first person view itself feels a bit
heavy-handed in its callback to the
games there's a more subtle easter egg
incorporated into the scene that only
fans of the games will recognize at one
point master chief takes a heavy amount
of plasma fire from an attacking elite
and his hud shows that his energy
shields are temporarily depleted he
quickly ducks behind the nearest
available cover to wait for his shields
to come back this isn't just a nod to
the mechanics of halo games which were
some of the first to introduce the
concept of regenerating shields instead
of a traditional health pack system it
also uses the exact same sound effects
for the shields being broken and
subsequently coming back
the halo show uses a number of specific
audio cues from the games and the shield
noise is sure to flash players back to
all the times they had to hide behind
cover
within just the first action sequence of
the halo tv series master chief and his
spartan comrades exhibit a wide array of
moves and tactics pulled directly from
the video games many viewers will
recognize the weapons themselves which
include the standard issue unsc assault
rifle sniper rifle handgun and marksman
rifle but the allusions to the games go
further than simply the guns themselves
the way master chief fights on madrigal
is spot on to the combat flow halo
players know so well because of his
armor and shields master chief maneuvers
pretty freely in the open only using
cover when his defenses are briefly
knocked out he also makes good use of
hand grenades and melee attacks two key
pieces of the so-called combat puzzle
that's always made the gameplay and halo
so engaging one specific sequence has
master chief toss a grenade at a group
of elites use it as covered in moving
close and deliver some brutal physical
blows with the butt of his rifle that
batter down the enemy's shields
it's an approach anyone who's played the
games will be familiar with even if it
might not be so easy to pull off at home
to top it off master chief picks up a
fallen minigun dislodged from its mount
and wields it like it's nothing a
specific reference to a mechanic
implemented in halo 3.
in their investigation of the covenant
ship on madrigal master chief and silver
team happen upon an excavation site and
a mysterious artifact at its center the
device turns out to be a keystone a
relic from the ancient 4runner race with
ties to the mystical and deadly halo
rings all of this lore only alluded to
in the show's first episode harkens back
to the games in interesting ways but
there's a specific easter egg mixed into
the scene that only eagle-eyed viewers
will catch when master chief first
activates the keystone by touching it a
symbol appears a relatively nondescript
circle within a circle this symbol is
actually the logo for the video game
marathon another property developed by
bungie in the years before the release
of halo curiously marathon features many
narrative similarities with halo and can
be seen in some ways as an elaborate
prototype for the franchise
themes like human colonization of space
alien wars and rogue ai all play into
the marathon story just as they do in
halo
one of the more interesting parts of the
halo show is that it features scenes
from the covenant side of the war as
early as the first episode these scenes
take place on high charity the massive
spaceship slash planetoid that serves as
the capital of the alien force high
charity appears prominently in the halo
games as do the prophets the enigmatic
race of older wisdom spacefarers who
lead the covenant forces the show's
version of the vessel is pretty much an
exact match to the high charity of the
games a bulbous mushroom-like structure
of the covenant's signature purple the
halo scenes aboard high charity in the
series early episodes include a number
of smaller easter eggs for game fans as
well such as references to the great
journey the core belief of the covenant
religion which is tied to the halo rings
and specific characters like the prophet
of mercy and the prophet of truth a
major change in the paramount plus halo
series is the human character maki who
appears to be a genuine ally of the
covenant her inclusion is one of the
major departures from the games in which
the covenant was never known to accept a
human into the ranks it remains to be
seen why this particular human was check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and tv shows are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]